( intro music )
( applause )
So, a lot happens, a lot
starts here in Washington DC.
For me, it was my career,
there's a lot else
that's going on here
too, which is that
Washington has the distinction
of being one of the great
capitals of the world
for cocaine consumption.
There is greater per
capita cocaine use here
particularly among
white collar workers,
second only to New York.
So, what I want to do is begin
in this point of consumption,
of cocaine consumption
and take you back down
the commodity chain.
Not to where we typically
think of
when we see these crazy maps
full of arrows pointing north.
Not back to where coca
is grown and cocaine
is produced in South America,
but rather
I want to take you halfway
back down the commodity chain
to those areas hiding
under those red arrows
in Central America.
Those spaces through which
cocaine is merely moved
like packages in a DHL hub,
these are trans-shipment zones,
through which cocaine moves
on its journey northward
to markets such as those
I'm sure
just outside the door here.
So, I want
to take you specifically
to look at a region
in Eastern Honduras.
It's known
as the Mosquito Coast region
of Eastern Honduras
and Nicaragua
and this is an area
of tremendous biological
and cultural diversity.
It has many protected areas,
internationally recognized
world heritage sites and so on,
and I want
to take you specifically
into the communities
of the Tawahka people.
They're one of Honduras'
smallest ethnic groups,
fewer than 2000 people.
They're regionally known for
the spectacular dugout canoes
that they produce
almost entirely by hand,
no chainsaws here,
just pure axe and ads.
And I want to take you
through the ways
that I've become aware that this
is an area that is being
both culturally and
ecologically devastated
by both the consumption
here in the US of cocaine,
but also what I would argue are
the US' deeply flawed policies
with regards
to the global war on drugs.
Alright, so how did
I get into drugs? Well...
( laughter )
After working
the National Geographic
I went to live in Eastern
Honduras for two years,
working on a research
project there
and that began a career
as a geography professor,
by which I've been very
privileged to be able
to repeatedly return
to this place over time.
And that has allowed
a wonderful opportunity
to really understand the very
dynamic relationships between
people there and the forests
with which they coexist.
And I've learned a lot
about how forests
make people and people make
forests in this region.
And one of the things
that my repeat research trips
to the region had shown me,
and really convinced me of
was just how profoundly
resilient the Tawahka people
and the ecosystem which
defines them have been.
And by resilient I
mean they have shown
a remarkable ability
to bounce back.
For example, in the 1930s
their population
was devastated by
a smallpox epidemic.
They were reduced
to about 100 people.
And it was through the choices
made by women like
Doña Rufina here,
she was pushing 100 when
I saw her in 2011, she just
died before Christmas last year.
Because there were so
few Tawahka men to marry,
she... among her six husbands--
Life is short...
( laughter )
in the region for men,
snakebite, disease
and other things.
Among her six husbands there
was not a single Tawahka man,
but she raised all of
her children to speak
Tawahka and to learn
the Tawahka way.
So, all of her children,
though genetically diverse,
incorporating much
non-Amerindian blood,
they nevertheless
speak Tawahka
and identify themselves
culturally as Tawahka.
So, she and other women
like her have been
essential for passing on
what it is to be Tawahka.
Tawahka have also been extremely
successful at bouncing back
from the threat of colonist
incursion into their territory.
Savvy political leaders
like Edgardo Benitez
have been able to
organize international allies
to have in 1999
their territory declared
the Tawahka Asangni
Biosphere reserve.
And then, perhaps most
impressively
after Hurricane Mitch wiped out
two of their communities and
almost all of their
horticultural and
agricultural lands,
decades worth of
agroforestry plots,
they were able to
rebound in a way
that used the storm as
a window of opportunity
to reorganize their
agricultural activities
and to, in fact, be more
sustainable planting
precious trees like
Mahogany for example.
So, it was with funding
from the committee
for research and exploration
from National Geographic
that I returned in 2011
to Tawahka territory
thinking that I was going
to be able to research
the latest ways in which
they were manifesting
their cultural, their
socio-ecological resilience.
I went down with an
undergraduate and a
graduate student
and it had been a while
since I'd been back,
I had two kids,
I had gotten tenure and
this had been my
longest time away.
After three days of
traveling through the region
to get into the Tawahka
area by dugout canoe...
This is the community
prior to our visit.
This is what we saw.
We saw landscapes
just devastated.
This is the site where
a community I'd known
and where I had eaten
my first monkey
and drunk all sorts of
fermented beverages...
( laughter )
...people were gone, I was
told they fled to Nicaragua.
Some of them were living
poor in the capital city.
We saw patterns of
deforestation
I've never seen before right
down to the water's edge
on incredibly steep slopes
and when I talk to people
about what was going on,
they kept telling me
the same thing, "narcos."
Now, when I had lived in
this area in the mid-90s,
we heard planes in the night,
I mean, cocaine has been moving
through Central America
since the disco era
and I was able to use,
knowing the local language
and being able to talk to people
and the 20 years of trust
I've built up in this region
to really ask people
what was going on.
Why were drugs, why was
the mere passage of drugs
through this area
having this effect?
And key to understanding
this is to understand
that when a plane lands
and is unloaded of let's say,
700 kilos of cocaine,
the plane is burned,
that gives you immediately
an idea of how little the
plane is worth relative
to its cargo, it's just
not worth flying back.
So what you see is an
absolute tsunami of money
hitting these communities
that comes with,
that buys impunity
and that buys weapons.
So, traffickers in this region
have been able to buy up
land from Tawahka and
other indigenous groups
and pay for the labor
to have that forest--
the forest lands
converted into cattle pasture.
And they're doing it in huge
swaths, 500 hectares at a time.
And the question is why
would drug traffickers
want to be interested
in cattle ranches?
Well, these are untraceable
transactions right?
So, they're a wonderful
way to launder drug profits,
otherwise known
as land laundering.
And in fact, when
the US Treasury Department
froze the assets of a Honduran
trafficking organization,
they found that a lot
of the assets that they held
were in palm plantations
and cattle ranches.
So, it's a great way
to launder money,
but it's also a really excellent
way for criminal organizations
to diversify
their investment portfolios.
They are good capitalists
like everyone else
and they are investing
in the tropical land rush
driven in part by high
demand for ethanol,
which is fueling, literally,
the expansion of African
oil palm plantations.
These were planted on
illicit lands,
on lands illicitly purchased,
very close to the Mosquitia,
in fact, moving in to
the Mosquitia
and the result,
of course, is that
the money
narcos can manipulate
buys complicity
with government officials,
leaving the Tawahka
very much on their own
to fight this scourge.
And not surprisingly,
this was a group of men,
of Tawahkan mosquito men
who went to challenge
some traffickers
who were clearing
land very close
to their territories
and they were rebuffed
with AK-47s and M-16s.
So, leaders are threatened
if they speak out,
there was literally no one
in the region
to witness this process.
No one knew this was going on.
And so, Tawahka are also
unable to move
through their traditional,
seasonal agricultural
and fishing activities,
so they're stuck
fishing for crappy little fish
near their home communities
because they are not
allowed, basically
they're sealed off by a narco
cordon to secure the area.
And perhaps one of the
most pernicious effects of
the traffickers is their
tremendous skill
at being able to pit,
their divide and
conquer strategies,
their ability to turn
neighbors against neighbors.
So, one of the things
they do
in approaching a remote
indigenous community
is identify that weakest link,
that one family that
is so poor
that they can act
as the land consolidators
on behalf of the narcos and this
pits family against family.
This is a picture of Walter.
I took it in...
about nine years ago.
We were finishing up household
survey in his community.
He's in the
one-room schoolhouse
that has since
been sold to narcos
and we were having
a little dance.
Walter and his brother this
past Easter had heard that
their cousins were clearing
land for narcos in the area.
He went to confront those narcos
and was killed with an M-16.
The man behind these children
is the man who shot him
and I know this man.
He was a lovely man,
he's the father
of these four
and other children.
These are good people caught
in an impossible situation.
And they really are hanging
on by their fingernails.
This incredibly resilient
community that I once knew
is as the Tawahka leader said,
"really not far
from disappearing."
So, the question is what
can we do about this?
I think one of the things that--
There are three things
we can do.
One, tell your friends who
recreationally consume cocaine
just what the cost of their
recreational use
is doing to places overseas.
Second, I think we really need
to rethink the war on drugs.
We're not talking about
legalizing cocaine.
Let's not get carried away here.
Just talking about
sitting down and reviewing
drug policy orthodoxy,
which has for 40 years
done nothing
but move traffickers
into ever more remote regions
where they create
all sorts of social and
ecological chaos,
not to mention the damage
going on in urban areas.
I think the Organization
of American States
has broken with drug
war orthodoxy,
it's one of the first big
organizations to do so.
I'm working with the UN,
UNDP and the UNEP
to kind of change
the conversation
within the UN system
so that they can get on board
with kind of ways to
rethink the drug war.
But I think also,
we'd have to look
at the ways in which
our retirement portfolios
and other financial mechanisms
and the fear over not having
enough farmland in the future
are pushing financial markets
to take great interest
in tropical forest lands
and their destruction.
And I think there are
alternatives to that.
Wasting less food
is one of them.
Using more solar energy
so we don't need to
be feeding African oil palm
to our cars is another.
So, let's think about
those things,
about connecting the dots
and understanding
how we are all complicit
in the destruction of this
really quite unique place.
Thank you.
( applause )
( outro music )